hello
and welcome to our career webinar
exploring analytic marketing with expert
tips to become a successful analytical
marketer today
our guest today is jay pankaj who is
director of marketing technology and
analytics
for proctor and gamble india
more about him in a moment
here's just a couple of tips on using
the webex
controls please enter your questions for
jy in the q and a
panel so that we can address those in
the q a
portion of the webinar toward the end
and remember to ask all panelists
you can put chat information in for
all panelists in the chat box
um we will take a look at that from time
to time but the questions are better put
into the q a box and i will
now introduce jai uh pankaj who is
the director of marketing technology and
analytics for procter gamble india
and he is focused on unleashing the
power of data and technology
to meaningfully engage with consumers as
you know procter
gamble is one of the largest
consumer products manufacturers in the
world
with a history of over well well over
100 years
um so before
we talk to john i would he's asked us to
run a quick poll question
and try you can um mute yourself if
you'd like
good morning from california being in
india
yeah good morning good afternoon good
evening to everybody my pleasure to be
with all of you thank you for taking the
time to
invest in personal development
i've opened the pool
and uh i'd like our viewers on
youtube live and linkedin live can also
uh engage in the poll by leaving a
comment
question number one how much work
experience do you have
question number two where in the world
are you based
and most interesting for jai is
you'd like to know what you believe
marketing is what its purpose is
so please answer all three questions and
hit submit
the poll will stay open for about
another 20 seconds
and in five four
three two one
here are the results
so yeah most people have more than five
years of experience
um i think we're heavily uh
an asian probably indian audience
but i i i'd like you to comment on that
third poll question and then i'm going
to throw
the presenter function over to you john
yeah absolutely so welcome once again to
everybody it's my pleasure to be with
you
and as i said uh you must congratulate
and pack yourself
back for investing in your own personal
development
by attending uh this uh session
i i'd like to answer to another team and
you
are right on you think holistically and
the role of marketing is not like just
to make ads or put out the right
communication
but it is really for us to grow the
business
so let's dive right in and i'll share my
screen
and if you have any questions or
comments along the way
use the chat feature
excellent hopefully you can see my
screen store
oh yes excellent
all right so today's uh before i start
today's uh topic i wanted to start with
a quote and i
didn't know if you can see it very well
on the stream but essentially
john wannamaker said back in early 1900s
that half the money i spend on
advertising is wasted the trouble is i
don't know which have
and while it speaks to a much narrower
definition of what marketing is supposed
to do
i think uh it hits the nail on the head
in trying to identify where the problem
really lies
john was founded a few companies and
which became the predecessor to what we
know today as the macy's department
so in terms of the agenda i go deeper
into my introduction so stuart thank you
for
for setting the stage and uh and doing
the brief introduction
i want to go a little bit deeper into my
own analytics experience and career
um we got to know you are ready through
the poll so
great to know that most of you are based
in asia most of you have
experienced more than five years so i'll
try and tailor my content accordingly
and we'll then touch on what we feel or
think is marketing analytics
and there is what is
i i feel a much sharper definition but
there's also a very holistic definition
and we'll look at those
um what can you expect when you enter
into the field of marketing analytics
if you're not already there and then
as i had promised in my teaser i want to
share a couple of frameworks with you
and i feel
from my experience that these frameworks
are super powerful
and not only in marketing analytics but
if you are
anywhere in that area of analytics this
should serve you very very well
and lastly what are the skills uh for a
successful career
in marketing analytics so
starting with my own introduction um
today this is
about my 18th year uh in my career
and most of my life i spent in the area
of analytics so i've done a business on
this role at a
technology firm i have run a large
analytics factories uh
where we were working with strategic
partners and i've run
a global marketing analytics service
inside doctor and gamble as well
and lately also looking at data science
in the area of
of media analytics so um
suffice to say that i've spent enough
time in in the field of analytics
to be able to pass on some of that
experience
back to back to this crew
so let's go to what is marketing
analytics uh
now as you know on the marketing side
often it is described as the four
piece and the four p's are
starting with product so definitely as
uh
an analytics person in the area of
marketing one of your jobs could be to
identify
what is the right product that we need
to bring
in our portfolio that might be missing
today as you know consumer
tastes and trends evolve over a period
of time
and it is very important that we keep
our ears firmly to the ground
to understand what products will sell
are selling
by analyzing the data that is coming out
the data could be something as simple as
understanding what is really selling in
the market
because as any reasonable size company
you will have
hundreds of skus and to be able to
understand
which sku what size what form what
variant
is selling in a particular corner of
photography is going to
help you understand what are the tastes
that
the consumers and shuffles have so
product is one aspect of the analytics
and that's why i want
to take a more holistic view of
marketing analytics than just focus
on advertising or communication which is
often
what is cited when we talk about
marketing
the other area of a product that we need
to
think about from a data source point of
view is really
all the consumer complaints for example
that you your
your support teams might be getting that
is a very rich source of data
to tap into to understand uh what is the
source of dissatisfaction
that your consumers have so that you can
loop that back in and improve the
products as
uh as the feedback might suggest the
other source
uh and vital so today in the uh from
from all the online shopping that is
happening is the customer or consumer
reviews and ratings
if you're able to mine that data there's
a ton of insight there to understand
what is uh right or wrong about your
product
or you're about your service that you
can go address
so i wanted to begin with using the
construct of the four piece framework
um how you can focus on
the first p and what are the data
sources that is
that are really relevant for product
the second one is of course price and
it's no secret that price is a big
factor for
the overall commercial success of any
corporation
or enterprise and uh
as a variable you know you can look at
it and look at the sensitivities that
the sales has to price
and understand what is the ideal pricing
that you want to maintain
for your products or brands uh place
which speaks to what channels are you
selling it through what retailers
what formats that you are selling it in
and you need to maintain
um different skus for different channels
and so on
and lastly what is more commonly
understood to be promotion or
communication
this is where we want to
look at advertising both online and
offline
and understanding uh on the online side
particularly the entire consumer fund
so starting with how many people clicked
on your ads to how many people landed on
your website
you haven't browsed or touched a
particular product
how many added to cart and how many then
uh checked out
and then also on the offline side
similarly the
world of advertising is full of
opportunities for us to understand
um each the roi of every marketing
dollar that you spend
and there are various models that are
available
for for you to play around in this area
there is the traditional
uh mmn or market mix modeling there is
nothing but uh
that a multivariate regression um that
you try to identify
through aggregated variables and the
impact of
different components of your of your
support model
and what's the impact that it is having
on the overall business
in the field of offline so that's mmm is
very prominent
now of course in online we have what we
commonly
refer to as mta or multi-touch
attribution
and there again there are multiple uh
there are multiple models available last
like uh
first flick and and and so on so again
you don't necessarily have the time
today to go deeper into
each of these but uh online offline
and the impact of advertising on
um final output is a very important area
for
all of us to think about and the other
one
online that is becoming quite popular
these days is
using the data to truly understand how
can we personalize
um who is likely to see what kind of ads
what should you communicate in those ads
now those are all driven by analytics
and that's why
i do feel that marketing is changing
fundamentally
in how people get communicated and
reached out to
so that hopefully gives you some idea
about
what we mean when we say marketing
analytics it is more comprehensive than
just for some advertising
and in the field of advertising as well
you can look at online offline and then
together both of them
now i promise to give you a couple of
frameworks so let's
go right into it and this is uh
not necessarily very specific to
marketing analytics but uh much broader
and you can
uh you can think about applying it
wherever you are
[Music]
so the framework one that i call this is
collect the reds
now whenever you look at your business
you can look at it along various
dimensions
you can look at it by your customers by
your consumers
by your retailers by your distributors
you can look at the total business
sliced up by what geography or state or
city the business is happening
you can slice up your business by
looking at what products
sku sizes forms
variants
that they belong to and you can use any
combination of these so you can say
in city a mystery one
how is that doing and as you
break your total business down into
these smaller parts
some businesses some parts of the
business will be doing well and other
parts of the business may not be doing
that
and that's where if you look at it an
aggregate level you may
feel that uh on the whole the business
is reasonable
um it's uh overall it's meeting all the
kpis and you mark it as a green and you
move on
and you look at something else but if
you
if you took the moment to look at the
individual
slices that you have sliced up and
you identify the reds then you have a
much
deeper opportunity to go and make the
interventions even though at the
on on the outside it may look like
everything is happening
there are parts that still need
attention and when they are attended to
mended and carefully nurtured and
brought back to green the overall
business is even
stronger so often um i have made this
mistake in the past as well
where once you look at the business on
the outside
at an aggregate level without slicing
and dicing it up as much as you could
it gives you potentially the wrong
indicators
so it's very important again to look at
all the dimensions of
product of customer of geography of
consumer what have you and then slice
them up into as many combinations
there will be thousands of combinations
but uh
and each of those combinations you look
at it individually and
under the glass and the microscope and
try and understand whether
there are any reds there and if there
are reds can you collect all of them
quantify what the size of price is if
you turn
these reds into greens and take that
back as the inside
from from your data
and and as you presented you need to be
very clear
as to where the largest impact is going
to be because often
there is a full queue of
intervention opportunities that is
available to any decision maker
and that's why if we were able to
quantify that
in this particular intervention when
fixed or addressed
can lead to x amount of business
and and you sort the intervention
opportunities for the impact that they
can generate
and that really helps that
really helps in pushing your point
across
and the second one is really to to jump
by
jump to inside and this is where
um i take this picture
that it may be a thousand page book and
you are
flipping through the book one page at a
time not
knowing where really the insight is and
our job really as
people in analytics is to make sure that
people don't have to die
by browsing and flipping through pages
one after another
but they are really able to get to the
right page
instantly and get the insights uh
directly
so how can you um
how can you prevent this tendency
sometimes where we create
these tools and dashboards that require
people to go
click you know change their filters
change their drop downs
multiple times browse through like a 20
page dashboard
to eventually get to the one or two key
insights that they might walk away with
and when when the design is such it
probably is not very
conducive to driving the right action in
the right result
amongst other people and
as you try to jump to insights what i
have found very useful
is to think in terms of calibration so
you often need to have a benchmark to be
able to say this part of my business is
doing well or not
and you can often do that along two
lines in my mind
one is if you can look at your own
relative performance
uh versus time gone by and see whether
that performance is doing better than
than than previously and the second one
is to look at the comparison across
peers so
how are you how is your competition
doing or how are
other brands in a similar category doing
that you may that may come from your own
portfolio
so you can calibrate along the time
dimension
or you can calibrate against your peers
and you will get a very interesting
insights
on what parts of the business really
need improvement
i will pause here before i go into the
next section to see if there are any
questions that you have at this time
[Music]
i think one of the questions that
has come up is when you refer to the
reds
can you elaborate a little bit more on
um what those are in terms of
you know where you're seeing the red and
red indicators and
and how you collect those
absolutely so you can take any metric
for example
so let's take the metric of sales and if
you define success to be
that i need to be selling 30 higher than
last year because the market is really
going uh very well then
red in that circumstance would be
anything that is growing less
and as you cut up your business into
thousand different
pockets and look at each pocket
individually under a magnifying glass
you go
and measure each of those pockets by
that parameter whether
the business is not growing uh 30
and if it is not growing 30 you mark it
as a red and then you collect all those
businesses together because it could be
very well the case that
some businesses are growing at 70
percent others are growing at 80 percent
while some businesses are not growing at
all and on the aggregate if you left it
like that
it could be that the on the aggregate
the business is growing 45
and then you call it like green and you
move on
but the intent is to find out all those
red pockets even if there are
five out of thousands there are 20 or a
thousand
you collect them up because if you
intervene and make them greener right
now
your business is going to be even
stronger even though from the outside
this doesn't seem too many
issues
okay and uh let's then uh
turn our attention to the successful
career and
this is a topic that is very close to my
heart
as to what does it take for someone to
have a very successful career as an
analytical marketer
as with all things in analytics i think
it starts with an understanding of the
business that you're trying to draw
very important that you spend the time
in the field uh
share the people who are actually going
to use these
these tools and these insights
participate in those meetings
that's very very important that we start
with having a very acute understanding
of other business itself um
[Music]
somewhere some research pointed out that
the best analyst
is seven times better than the analyst
at the bottom
so there is a wide vari variance between
uh the best and and the others and
that's
where imagine um you know if if
you are working with one of
the analysts who is still coming into
the system
and learning and improving uh
the best analysis as good as seven of
them so that's the that's the
wide gulf that we are talking about
and it also is good news in a way that
if you continuously hone your skills and
improve your skills
you are likely to distinguish yourself
because
the best analysts are very very few in
number
the other one that i wanted to talk
about was
it's not i don't necessarily see
an analytical career to be
to be lined up against a function and
and when i say function i need mark
meaning finance sales and so on
so you may be on analytical marketeer
one day and you may specialize there
but you would have enough rights to
come and look at other parts of the
business
and focus on uh the supply chain side of
advance or
focus on the commercial side or sales
side of our distribution cycle and
and that would be equally uh within
within
your grasp because what is most
important is first to understand the
business
then of course you build some depth in
understanding a function
but the business comes first and the
function comes second
and not the other way around um
so so that's what i wanted to make sure
that we fully understand
the second one is uh on data and uh
in as people in this area we all know
that
even the best and most experienced data
scientists spend about 70
of their time straightening the data out
and our data is a real real problem
it's like um you know a wardrobe that
has
uh uh that is very jumbled up
and you can't find what you really need
to wear that
so today the problem is not that we have
a lack of data in fact the problem is
that there's a
excess of data and we don't know which
one to look at
and and how to make sense of it and
that's why
understanding that data going with some
data engineering skills
as well uh because sometimes as
as as people in the analytics field we
may be
super focused on querying the data
structuring our hypothesis having the
identity mindset
visualizing the data and bringing the
insights
back to the teams that we serve but we
can really distinguish
ourselves if we also focus on some of
the upstream
needs that can really solidify
our work further because if 70
of the work is really inspirating the
data out why won't we
build more skills and deepen our our
understanding of that space because that
can really
make the biggest difference in the
results that
that you can try
next is of course the tools so while it
is good to have
understanding of the tools that your
company or your business is using
it is sometimes equally important to
step back and look at what are the
alternatives that are also available
because then you can make the right
choices suggest the right options for
the organization as well
and lastly as i said you know being very
proficient
in technology is very very important in
my mind
if you're not very good
in creating a data model or
[Music]
you know writing the sql queries and so
on
i know sometimes it is the work is
separated and that responsibility
belongs to a security
but you will really do well to if you're
particularly if you're still starting
out
you will do well to deepen your skills
as far as
you know database skills are concerned
uh as far as some of the data
engineering skills are concerned
just so you know there was a poll by
the cmo magazine if i'm not mistaken and
all the chief marketing officers were
bored and they were asked
what percentage of people um
do you have the right right set of
people in your organization as far as
analytics are concerned is concerned and
the answer was can you guess
only two percent of the cmos believe
that they have the right yeah
and that's uh really the state of uh
affairs it's really
uh quite telling that
the confidence level is so low that in
no single digits
that most people think that they lack
the right team to to take it forward and
to take their hunting journey
so that's that's about all i have so i
would turn now
to any questions or
that might be there on on the on the
chat
it's good
yeah i'm going to
pull up the question sheet
and um
sir of right asks how much does
analytics have to do with statistical
know-how
yeah that's a good question i i think
uh it's got a lot to do with the
statistical statistical know-how
especially the basis
as you as you get started and as you
advance
[Music]
you need to fish it up with it
so at a basic level
grade 8 max is just good enough to be
honest
at a very basic level and that itself
can drive a lot of badminton
but as you go more advanced and looking
for correlation
looking for modeling um
then it becomes very important that you
have a very sound statistical
basis you should be able to understand
what your need is
uh at least read up if you don't
remember what you work in school
and be able to fully grasp it so
as a person in you should be very
comfortable with the mathematics
you should be very comfortable with the
statistical concepts
because otherwise the models that you
bear
they will not be standing on very
firm foundations and that's very
important
i see one here by jambe doji and
is asking what is the future of digital
marketing
i think the world is going towards
digital marketing
and with the proliferation of
low-cost data with the access of
low-cost smartphones more and more
people are going to be
on digital mediums and more and more
people are going to
uh watching their their content that
otherwise they would have consumed the
television they would be watching on
on digital and that is why more and more
companies are going to spend more and
more of their advertising dollars
on digital and it becomes very important
that
we as companies know how to
judge the effectiveness of those digital
marketing spending and dollars
so in my mind i think the digital
marketing is going to be
twice as important or twice as important
in three years time
than it is now such is the speed at
which
companies are embracing digital
marketing such as the speed at which
the ecosystem is evolving towards
digital marketing
a question from um
one of our users who asks if
you require a degree to become
uh as an entry qualification into the
field
or can you acquire qualifications
in another way yeah
i don't think you need a degree to be
honest uh
of any kind to be a marketing analyst
you could very well do
courses that are available now on simply
learn and
other platforms where you can
demonstrate
or first pick up the skill and then
apply it
one of the best examples i saw recently
was a graduating student had put out
some kind of uh vision about
how the ratings of the simpsons program
in the us
had evolved over its
10 or more seasons and each season had
more than a number of episodes to
suggest
that while the first two seasons were
hit the latest seasons were mixed and i
don't know whether that was accurate or
not
but the output that the person had
generated and boosted
was marvelous to see in quite
professional and it's
in its appeal and if you can demonstrate
that you've
picked up some skills you need to apply
those skills either
um through a work that you put out there
in your blogs or on linkedin
or um even in
in online forums like kaggle you will
have the right credentials for people to
uh want to to work with you and use your
skills to impact their business so
i definitely don't think you need to
have a degree or a background already
but you can certainly pick up the skills
but it is very important that one of the
skills that you do
you go deep into it because
as you saw on the other slide the best
analysts are
7x more productive than the
than the worst analyst so you don't want
to be anywhere at the bottom
because it's very quick for
organizations to realize
uh where in the fact you are um and
and you need to be careful about that
okay um even from our linkedin live
stream asks how important are coding
skills like python
in a marketing analytics career
they're becoming increasingly
increasingly important now
you could without it uh for a period of
time
but uh sooner than later you have to
start acquiring it because if you don't
start acquiring it you will
become very limited in your ability to
create
an impact so you know four years back
five years back we wouldn't look for a
python
uh experience uh but now it's almost
becoming based in the states so
either r or python you've got to come in
with
the knowledge of those
and and it is to your own benefit
because you know once you're proficient
with those
um you will be able to do things much
faster
our vendor asks um
as an analyst working in digital
marketing space
um how can upskill in terms of business
knowledge
can you say that again so yeah the
question is
as an analyst working in digital
marketing
how can one upskill
in terms of uh the business knowledge
yeah it's by
being in the trenches so
as far as the business knowledge is
considered
you can visit you can go with your
market research colleagues
start visiting consumers homes if that
is the way your organization works
so you cannot sit and listening to what
the consumer is really saying
about their experience so that's one way
to really deepen your knowledge
uh be in the field you know talk to the
retailers of the people who are actually
making this
doing the selling there's no no
substitute for
actually spending time on the field the
second one
is really participate in all the
discussions um where the strategy is
being conceived
where the reviews are happening on a
periodic basis
and even though you may feel like as an
analyst that's not
where you are actually adding direct
value
it's very important for you to have a
broader perspective on
what the organization's strategy is and
uh
and use that to inform your hypothesis
and analysis
the third one is it is very important
for you
to actually use the product yourself so
it goes without saying and i
hope that many of you wherever you are
you're already consuming
the products that your organization is
selling but very important it's the
first time
as much as possible the fourth one i
would say
is to have a good pal
in the business yourself who you can ask
on the questions that you would
otherwise hesitate to ask in a much
larger and more people
go ask these questions be curious
and and get your answers so that you can
truly
internalize all the
facets and aspects of of your business
so that's how i would say you can uh
deepen your business
here's an another question from the
linkedin stream um
kind of a technical question what are
the dimensions
that we need to consider
when we set the ideal price for a
product
when you set the ideal price of the
product there are many main things that
that come into play one is the
attractiveness of your product uh
relative to
[Music]
uh what is available already in the
market
it depends on how you're positioning the
product the same product can cost
2x if your the packaging is different if
the communication is different and if
you give
a more clear so it depends a lot on
uh your strategy that you're playing as
a portfolio you may already
have a product already
existing for decades at a certain price
point and you want to play
your portfolio by bringing another
another
product at a higher price point or lower
price point and so on
so it depends on a number of variables
uh
but most important is the intrinsic work
and the value that your product is
adding to the life of
the consumer the shop and then other
aspects around it in terms of what is
your own portfolio strategy
so that's number two and number three is
how much is the consumer really going to
and that you kind of establish through
your initial transfer test or you can
establish
through consumer research um and then
also you
do a landscape assessment to say what is
the market operating at
and understand how the market is divided
across many different price price points
and where do you have a right to winner
right
all of that by the way sounds like um
the role of the analytic marketer is
central in each of those steps
absolutely absolutely there is a ton of
data to inform those
those decisions to understand where the
white space is
uh to understand where you have a right
to win of course you go ahead and hand
with
your colleagues for math research
um one of our youtube live
users asks what types of tools like
[Music]
google analytics or other tools would do
you use
to obtain customer insights
certainly there are many different uh
tools that are available today uh
to get those insights uh google
analytics
is a key one there uh where you're able
to understand
for every consumer or what the path to
purchase or the consumer funnel
there are other rules that are available
and i'm not going to name
them but but there are tools for example
that do sentiment analysis and
google sentiment analysis and you will
get a list of many populations available
there
um that listen in on the consumer
reviews and understand
uh what is the consumer saying and
if there are any opportunities with your
product
um ion asks another technical question
which is you know how do you
ensure that indirect data sources are
relevant
and how do you validate them
how do you make sure indirect data
sources are relevant
yeah i'm not sure and what you mean by
indirect data sources i can only
guess what these indirect data sources
could be so
maybe we referring to
the data sources like the consumer
support data which
often people don't think about may be
considered to be indirect
i think they some of these interactive
resources tend to be
very illuminating because they've never
been looked at in the past for many many
years
and if you can cast your net wider and
bring in a fresh data source
you can get so much more information out
of it and really wow your audience
i remember a case where i mean back in
the very early days
you know some were not in my company but
outside
looked at some sample reviews uh
on online and they were able to match it
with what was happening
uh product uh on a time scale and they
were able to propagate they do even
qualitatively and that was
such an eye-opening insight for for the
organization so
definitely if that's what you refer to
as indirect uh
it's got a lot of potential and you
should always think uh
laterally to see what uh what data
sources we can bring
and and it sounds like one of the ways
that you validate those sources is to
look at
um whether the insights you draw
have any predictive value or
correspond to the other insights you've
drawn from other data sources yes
yeah absolutely okay
sarab asks with the advancement of
machine learning
and ai and blockchain and other
technology tools of that nature is that
going to make
the job of the
analyst and the analytic marketer easier
or is it going to make it more complex
that's an interesting one and i
think it's going to make it more
impactful so
it's definitely these tools
allow you to distinguish yourself from
what other people in the organization
can do
so with enough time anyone can take data
in put it on excel
and plow through it and get some basic
insights out
however when applied well and with the
right analytical hypothesis to begin
with
there are chances that these models will
help you differentiate yourself
at the same time allow you to answer
questions that were either to not
possible to answer and take that
to impact the business in a much greater
way
than you've done before so why it may be
uh more complex in the sense
that you've got to learn a new
technology you've got to learn and then
you've got to master it
but there is a lot of reward
for going through that and
and you don't necessarily always have to
go towards machine learning or become a
data scientist
uh yourself you can very well be a
a great analyst
and and there is a role for that as well
and there is a place and value that you
can
significantly add by by being an analyst
without venturing
into the more advanced uh deeper waters
so to say
um naveen asks
a question about
um ethics and privacy basically
the question is do analytical marketers
have a role in ensuring
data privacy or related aspects
data security and that type of thing
yeah absolutely i think data privacy
data security is the cornerstone
of everything that everyone
must do it is like walking on the street
and
following traffic signs you should not
think that another way is possible at
all
so understanding basics of data privacy
and data security is very very important
as you take your job on so for example
is it okay for you to communicate to
this consumer
have you got the right consent to be
able to be engaged with that consumer
basic things like that is going to be
very important as you try to engage with
consumers and market
them similarly on the cyber security
side and
i hope that there are more specialist
functions
in your organization that ensure cyber
security standards are fully met
but uh from an analytical uh
standpoint it is very important that if
the boundaries are defined
then you stay within those boundaries
and not venture further
donna asks what are your thoughts on
getting
online digital marketing certificate
are those valuable
yeah i think it is uh fairly valuable
as an analyst because it ties back to
the
question that one of you had about
gaining enough business understanding
and in fact
[Music]
two years three years back when i first
came into a marketing technology store
and by the way my role is
broader than just analytics
i and the organization requires us to do
a omca or online marketing certified
analyst course
and i remember at the time i went to
simply learn
and and did a fairly
arduous and difficult uh in the sense
that
it took many hours to complete it so i i
must have spent about 60 70 hours
completing that course and then after
that taking the omca exam
and i do feel that that set the
grounding
on understanding the online marketplace
and business
much much better and i was
finally able to understand that
in some cases you pay only for click
in some cases pay for impressions and
what's the difference between the two so
there were
many of these basics that were very very
clear
once uh i went for that digital
marketing uh course
so i i would recommend if you have the
chance and the opportunity
to ground yourself into the basics of
digital marketing
or online marketing that's always going
to be helpful
um we have someone who asks
whether a person with no technical
background
can enter this field
i i i don't know the specifics of
of the no technical background but i
definitely think everyone can enter this
field as long as you have the
inclination and having you to do so
even or regardless of whether you've
done it in the past
so if you think you are mathematically
inclined you're if you think you're
analytically built and if you
have the inclination to learn
um then there is and no stopping anybody
and the sky's the limit and
if you have the right drive and the
willingness and the information you
should be able to
acquire the skills in due course and
distinguish your stuff
but you have to ask yourself if you have
to ask yourself whether you
uh you want to do it
um we have a question
sauron asks whether domain knowledge
um is very important
in developing business understanding
i would not it helps
it helps but i don't think it is a
prerequisite because you
should be able to back yourself to say
that once you want to get closer to
developing your business understanding
opening it
then you will spend enough time to
acquire to acquire that
right so so so i don't know what you
mean necessarily by
by domain it could be one of two things
it could be
do i understand fmcg very well uh i'm
giving you the context of
so is that as a domain or a sector do i
understand that
or from a domain it could be do i
understand marketing very well
uh in either case i it helps to have the
same background but i don't think it is
a prerequisite and i
do think that the analytical skills are
transferable
easily between different sectors between
different
industries because the concepts in the
analytical bent of mind
remains the same uh it's very important
that you have a curiosity it's very
important
to understand the tools and how to apply
those tools
um we have a question from
a youtube user who says i'm working as a
mis executive uh i presume as management
information systems
and looking to go into
either digital marketing or data
analytics
um which branch would
you recommend this person start with
which branch of whether
whether they should approach it from
studying digital marketing first
and then analytics or uh analytics
first and then digital marketing
yeah i don't know there is a better
order to be honest i think we need to do
both eventually and it may be a matter
of a few months here
and there but if you're an mis person i
think you can definitely start by
acquiring the analytical skills
uh and the tools and the techniques
there because
that's going to be your calling card and
that's going to be your differentiating
factor versus other people on the team
so at least if you know that very well
then you can expect that another team
member in the wider team will bring the
map to know how initially uh to
eat the hypothesis setting to aid the
uh framing the business question and the
problem
so you can do that in tandem with
another person on the team but
if you don't have the analytical skills
or the know-how
to begin with then it is
even more difficult so i would probably
lean towards making the
analytical uh learning first of the
tools and techniques learning first and
then followed by
the learning of uh digital marketing
area
and i think the last question we have
is from a college student who
is considering whether digital marketing
or
marketing analytics with a better career
path
so what strengths
should she have when when
considering the two and which one
you know what are the deciding fact uh
strengths
and uh inclinations
yeah i if
if you don't like coding that i would
then i would lean towards
making maybe going towards digital
marketing uh instead of going to
marketing analytics because
i do feel that the world of marketing
analytics is going
in a direction where coding is going to
become a necessity
and if we don't like coding then
eventually you will
hit a ceiling and that's not going to be
something you like
so i would lean towards digital
marketing in an absolute uh
you know if that was not a constraint if
if
it's not a constraint or if you did like
coding
then there is a fabulous career path to
be had in either of those it all depends
on
your drive and and the approach
and the intent you bring to these areas
at work
and and that alone determines your
success but each of them have
fabulous opportunities as well
all right this has been a great session
and i do want to
thank thank you joy for being with us
today
um i've put up your linkedin
uh information so that people can reach
out to you
through that channel are there other um
things like uh other social media that
you
participated you know that's
that this is great uh yes please just uh
message me or add me on linkedin very
happy to connect there and take the
journey forward
hopefully uh you will uh or you are
users or simply gonna
go on to to look at what simply learn
has to offer as well
and uh and i have benefited a lot myself
from
from some of their courses and hope you
will enjoy it as well
thank you um i want to
mention uh one of the initiatives we
have here
at simply learn which is our skill up
program which provides free access
to over 300 skills trainings
and a thousand hours of video content
across a number of different categories
including digital marketing
and analytics and data science um
and you can see there and i've dropped
in the chat also linked
um our next webinar in our series
of career and expert webinars is
on january 27th about two weeks from now
on how tech and learning will redefine
the future of work
gupta who is the india country manager
for lincoln and
we hope that you all be able to join us
for that we'll be sending out
a link to
that webinar registration to people
who've been on this session today
and we do want to
thank you all for oops frank you know
for being here
you can connect with simply learn on our
social media channels as well
on facebook twitter
and linkedin and we are
looking forward to having you at future
events
and please do check out our our skill up
and again
last thank you to uh jaipankaj
for being here today and sharing his
insights with us
and thank you everybody that concludes
our webinar for today
thanks everyone
you